so my talk today is going to be mostly
expository and
more about ideas than results and the
topic i want to talk to you about i came
across about six some six months ago
when i started working on hiv with alan
perelson at los alamos national lab
and the adaptive immune system as i
learned was incredibly fascinating and i
thought it'd be
relevant for your audience here because
it is understood to be an evolutionary
process but it has been studied
in the perspective of computer science
as well so
it should have appeal to all of you um
so i'm going to start by motivating why
we would want to understand the adaptive
immune system
with hiv because as it turns out
to understand hiv and the immune
response to it
pushes what we know about the adaptive
immune system
so just we're just so that we're all on
the same page here's a graph of
the new hiv infections and hiv related
deaths in the past decade
this decrease in eight sorry aids
related deaths is mostly due to
antiretroviral therapy
so nowadays if you have access to
antiretroviral therapy and you're hiv
positive you can
live mostly a full life
and that's why you have this decrease in
aids-related deaths
and that's much better than the
situation 30 years ago but there are
some
disadvantages of antiretroviral therapy
one is that you have to keep taking it
through the rest of your life and that's
because
hiv as a virus has a the ability to
become latent
infected in a cell which just means it
once it enters a cell it doesn't
actively replicate so it's sort of
shielded from the immune system
but it can then start replicating
at any time that's not well understood
so that's why antiretroviral therapy
needs to be taken
to keep the viral load down and never
let
the latent cells activate and produce an
infection again
so that's one thing you have to take it
for the rest of your life the second
is if um
ait is stopped or antiretroviral therapy
is stopped there is a
chance that drug resistance will develop
so that's another risk
and there are also some side effects so
there are
lots of people trying to find other ways
to
treat vaccinate against or cure hiv
and one approach is an antibody based
vaccine
so let me explain this diagram
this gray picture is the spike protein
on the hiv virus so
the flat part of the top is the membrane
of the virus
this thing sticking out is the
gp41 gp120 spike and this is how the hiv
enters the cell
now these ribbon diagrams are different
antibodies that have been discovered in
just the last five years
and these antibodies have um the
property
that they can neutralize in the lab a
diverse range of hiv strains
and these are just their names the
different colors correspond to different
regions on the spy protein that they
attach to and some of which we
understand why they would neutralize
many different types for example the cd4
binding site
is where hiv first
one of the positions where hiv attaches
to enter a cell so it would make sense
that
this part is functionally conserved and
antibodies that can attach to that part
may be able to attach to many different
variants of hiv
so to give you a sense of how broad
these antibodies are this vrc01
can neutralize 90 of a
panel of 200 different hiv strains
and so people are very
excited about the discovery of these
antibodies
the problem is we don't really know how
to elicit them so they discover these
antibodies
by sorting the samples of blood cells
from
hiv patients they sort of know what
they're looking for so they sort these
cells they find them and they can show
that they neutralize a
large diversity but they don't actually
know how to elicit this
in a vaccine but what they can show
i should mention that in the patients
they find these antibodies in
those patients don't actually have any
better ability to fight hiv infection
so they find these antibodies they're
effective when tested against strains in
the lab
they don't seem to help when they're
developed naturally so the immune system
somehow produces them but they're not
useful in the infection what has been
shown though is if you take these
antibodies and
passively infuse them into non-human
primate models they seem to work quite
well so
on the next slide i have the results
just
that just came out this year where um
a lab took reese's monkeys and infected
them with simian hiv
and these are the different color lines
the different monkeys
and the y-axis is proxy for how much
virus they have in them
and then at a time point they inject one
of those
broadly neutralizing antibodies you saw
in the previous page so that's pgt 121
and then within a week you can see a
drastic drop in the viral load
this was just one injection and in three
of them it rebounded and
this one it actually stayed low they're
still following
that animal but the idea is if you get
these antibodies in
a host early enough and a larger
enough quantity they do work even though
in the host in which they arise in
they don't seem to do much
so yeah the challenge is how can we
elicit these
antibodies through vaccination
and it's unclear because of several
issues the first one is
when these antibodies were found in
individuals they typically found latent
infections so about two years
the vrco1 i told you about was after
nine years in the patient
they're not found in all infected
individuals that's not clear why either
i told you they had to sort through b
cells to find them so the fraction of
the total b cell population they
sample that are these broadly
neutralizing antibodies
is 0.1 they're highly mutated
and i'll talk more about that later and
they're typically not reactive to the
transmitted founder stream
so if you wanted to elicit
these antibodies you can't take the
transmitted strain in
the patient and the host and hope that
if you just inject this to
a attenuated version of this into
another host that you would get
that broadly neutralizing antibody
a lot of stuff has happened in between
in order to get to that
state so this really it's not clear how
you would do this with a vaccine
and if you think about it most diseases
where vaccines are successful
recovery from the disease gives you
immunity
hiv people don't recover from hiv so
how how would you devise a vaccine that
would
prevent hiv infection
and i should add that the researchers
who work on this have very
good data this is the resolution of data
they have
they take time samples of the virus this
is a phylogenetic tree of the virus
they can take time point samples of the
antibody populations
this tree the red lines red branches
represent the
antibodies they fished out then there
was a bioinformatics exercise to then
search through all the other antibodies
that were sampled to figure out what
might be in the same lineage so this
tree is just the antibodies sampled
which were predicted to be in the same
lineage as the red branches
this lower tree is um pulling out just a
few
sub-branches of that tree to study their
phenotypic properties the phenotypic
properties of the antibodies
in more detail the idea behind this
approach that
comes from larry liao and bart haynes
lab is that if we can somehow understand
the
lineage that led to these broadly
neutralizing antibodies
might we be able to simulate the same
lineage and guide the immune system
towards
those antibodies so do i say from this
the lineage was born very early on in
the infection
but they had lots of mutations rather
than it wasn't born like
okay so the ultimate common ancestor is
probably born early it had
in this picture it actually had two
branches one this lower branch
doesn't go on to neutralize broadly and
yes the other branch does so you can
think of it as it
did arise early but it had to undergo a
lot of mutations to get to
being broadly neutralizing okay so given
that even with this high resolution of
data it's still a challenging exercise
to figure out exactly what's going on
at least you know if you look at this
you can't see what are the evolutionary
processes that are leading to
the development of this family of rather
neutralizing antibodies
what we might want to do is try to model
what's happening
between the antibodies and the virus
and see if that can give us any idea of
why these broadly neutralizing
antibodies
occur and if we understand that can we
use that
to inform vaccine development
so in order to model that let's do
immunology immunology 101 in
10 minutes um the adaptive immune system
uh basically uses the idea of clonal
selection and affinity maturation
to uh fight infections so let me tell
you what that means
let's focus on the left chart here so
this is a time course
um the y-axis is serum antibody tighter
you can just think of that as the
measurement of how strong your immune
system is responding
to an antigen
antigen is just any molecule that
generates an immune response
so antigen a is added at this time point
and then there's some weak
primary anti-antigen a response that's
the red curve
there's no antigen b yet and then after
five weeks we add antigen a and antigen
b
you see that the response to antigen b
is now much stronger and faster that's
the red curve and
because this um host has not seen
antigen b before
it's um its response is the same as the
primary antigen a
for anti antigen a response so this
chart is
meant to show that the immune system has
memory
and it's specific to the antigen
now how does this memory get generated
and how is it specific
that comes from this figure on the right
so this big
shaded region is the germinal center
these are
located in our lymph nodes and what
happens
is when you get infected you have b
cells some naive some
memory let's just say they're not you
for now they're floating in your system
and they'll come in contact with an
antigen something you're infected with
and they become activated and this is
showing you that they're becoming
activated sometimes that activation
requires t cell help so that's this t
here and once they become activated they
go
migrate towards the germinal center and
in this general center
believe they enter in the dark zone and
what happens in the dark zone
is rapid proliferation and hypermutation
so these b
cells that are activated presumably
because they're good at recognizing this
foreign antigen
gets sent here to proliferate and mutate
so replication mutation and then from
the dark zone they move
into the light zone and what's believed
to happen in the light zone is that
there are these follicular dendritic
cells
ftc they display antigen so
particles from the invading pathogen
also get here
and the b cells that recognize these
particles will pick up
them so there's a um so when they pick
up these antigens there's a survival
signal
that's what c is and then they present
them again to t
cells these help the t cells and then
the t cells sort of do the selection
the more a b cell can present to a t
cell the stronger its survival
of the stronger its selection by the t
cell and then
it goes on to either become a plasma
cell which makes produces antibodies
it can become a memory cell it's unclear
how this happens can also recycle back
into the dark zone
so within the germinal center you
basically have
selection happening at a very small
scale and
arguably quite quickly um
i should mention each b cell recognizes
only one shape
one shape of molecule roughly how many
generations do you get about a week
seem to form about one week after the
infection
and then how long does it you mean how
many generations of proliferation
inside the dark zone do you get in about
a week i think that's unclear so in the
dark zone the replication rate is so the
generation time is six hours to 12 hours
how long do they stay in the dark zone
it's unclear
how much time b cells stay uh spend in
the germinal center versus in the rest
of the body is also unclear
but it's known that the generation time
is six to twelve hours
inside the dark zone any questions about
how german
general centers what
okay so just to give you some sense of
the the um
the system so that was one germinal
center in our
body there are about 10 to 11 b cells
and
a key point here is that there are tens
of imperial blood and
at least with humans the peripheral
blood is really where we sample our b
cells from so that's already only one
percent of all the b cells we
have in our body um experimentally it's
been seen that
about 10 to the negative five b cells
respond to any given molecule
so the way they measure this is
um they take say influenza
in mice and infect the mice and then
they look at this
lean cell so spleen is one of the organs
which contains a lot of
lymph nodes and they
test the b cells in the spleen to see
what fraction of them respond
to the molecule that they injected into
the mice so that's where 10 to the
negative 5
comes from and
it's difficult to measure this but the
theoretical germline
b cell receptor sequence diversity is 10
to the 13 amino acid sequences
so what i mean by that is the b cell
receptors are the antibodies that stick
out of the b cell
so those are the things that recognize
shapes
naive b cells are encoded in the germ
line so
b cells before they're exposed to any
foreign antigen
um are recognized shapes include code in
the germline
we know the way germline b cell
receptors are made it's a process called
vdj recombination
and there's variation in the v d and j
components there's also a variation in
how they're joined
and that variation in the back of the
envelope calculation gives you 10 to 13
amino acid sequences what the size is in
terms of phenotype and shape
i don't think people really know so this
is just a theoretical
number based on sequence diversity and
finally it's been measured that the
mutation rate of
b cells is ten to the negative three per
base per generation
but again mutation happens in the
germinal centers we don't know what
fraction of the time b cells spend in
the journal centers versus the rest of
the body
so um this is also just a ballpark
and uh so in a typical infection
how many mutations does it take for a
naive b cell to be
uh well adapted to the foreign antigens
so here's some data
um this is the number of mutations on
the variable
heavy chain gene it's just a
one of the important parts of the
antibody you can think of it as
representing
mutations on the entire antibody in a
naive
b cell so germline encoded b cell is
zero
igm and igg don't worry too much about
it these are memory cells so they've
already gone through
uh at least one round of affinity
maturation
these have mutations between 5 and 15.
if you look at b cells that
b cells after vaccination so here is a
primary sorry this is a primary
infection with anthrax or vaccinia
that's the response um 10 to 15
mutations
if you do full vaccines against anthrax
that's the number of mutations and
annual influenza vaccine and pandemic
influenza
have about the same so the idea here is
that one round of mutation probably one
round of affinity maturation probably
gives takes five to fifteen mutations
and then
if you think of these last three
examples as um
repeated exposure to the same pathogen
then you can think of this as the
previously developed
b cells against these the previous
infections
undergo further mutations which is why
the number of mutations is higher in
those cases
so if we wanted to model this system
in totality it's i mean 10 to 11p cells
is
quite large so is there a way to
sort of capture what's going on in the
antibody response without having to like
model this in detail but still capture
some of the complexity of this immune
system
so what i want to do now is just show
you some
models that have been developed for the
antibody response
so far and then talk about if we think
about this as
a search on a space of shapes
and formulated in the language of
theoretical computer science
might mean what might we be able to
learn something more about this
maybe not specifically in the case of
hiv but in general
could formulating it as a learning
algorithm give us some
idea of how the immune system works
abstractly
okay so if we think about the adaptive
immune response as something that
needs to solve a problem that problem is
finding the
a shape that matches very well to a
foreign antigen
so we first need some sense of a shape
space let's call that s
and in the shape space we need some
notion of distance
what i mean by that is if we have two
shapes
in our shape space if they're close
then we would say that if s1 is the
shape of the antibody and s2 is the
shape of the foreign antigen you want to
say that they bind well
but they have high affinity
and this notion of distance would then
play into the selective advantage of an
antigen
an antibody against say an antigen
also need to have some notion of
mutation
from some s to s prime in this space so
we need a space where we
have a notion of distance which
corresponds to how well things bind
and we need a space where we can we have
some notion of
how things mutate on the space and
finally we need some distribution of the
germline b cells
okay and once you have these you can
then do mutation selection and
basically genetic algorithm or
evolutionary algorithm on this to find
to
simulate what's going on in the immune
system
all right so let me give you a concrete
example of this so you guys have an idea
of
what what these things can be so for
example
you can take the shape space to be
bit strings of length l
so you can have a virus say it's one
zero one
this is a length eight bit string and an
antibody
but now let's just assume they're the
same length you don't have to do it this
way this is just to give you a flavor of
what you can do
okay so this is a virus an antibody and
a notion of distance well
since we're talking about bit strings we
have hamming distance which is just the
number of positions that are the same
you can also use longest common
substring
and the idea is here the shape space is
simultaneously the genotype and the
phenotype
it's convenient because mutation can
just be changing a bit
or a ladder and the phenotype is just
either the compara the hamming distance
between two or if you compare them what
is the longest common common subsequence
uh sorry longest common substring so
this level of abstraction
do mutations have to stay within a small
ball of the metric that defines
that you define on the shape space or
can mutations follow a different metric
from what is close
in terms of uh antigen antibody matching
i think you can so you're saying can
mutation be
of anything other than nearest neighbor
mutation yeah
yeah maybe it's a different metric
operating for what's the mutation that's
past one mutation might take you
far according to this metric if you use
for defining shape
similarity or or you think of these two
as the same metric or different metrics
you can think of them as different
metrics so um for example if i say
mutation is just flipping
one of the bits and um affinity
is longest common substring then
changing one
bit is going to move you very far in
that space
so you sort of have depending on how you
choose your notion of distance and the
mutation you can have
an implicit phenotype genotype map for
example
um okay so
some of the properties of this kind of
model so this is an abstraction it's
actually
still pretty simple if you talk to
immunologists about it but
it's already something that you can only
you can do mostly simulations with you
can't do much
analysis with but it has some nice
properties so the first thing
that it captures well that we also
observe in you know actual infections
is that an antibody can be
cross-reactive it can bind many
different antibodies
antigens so different viruses so you
have this notion of cross reactivity
and just by the way you define the
process and the selection
you will have affinity maturation you
will get
antibodies that bind a particular virus
well if you just infect with one virus
into the population
then just the selection process we'll
select for antibodies that bind it well
and you also get viral escape so if you
let
our immune escape if you let viruses
mutate as well
once the antibodies match it then the
more fit viruses are going to be the
ones that don't match
the available antibodies in the
population
okay so i've talked about the immune
system now let's take it back to hiv
in this system with the hiv there are
these broadly neutralizing antibodies so
how might you
represent broadly utilizing antibodies
under this framework
and it was sort of thinking about
broadly neutralizing antibodies that
made me wonder whether there might be an
alternative way of
modeling this so there are ways you can
do it using this framework you can
assume that there's a wild type
letter
asterisk and then eric any antibody with
a row of asterisks combine anything
another thing you can assume is that
there's a conserved or constant
region much like in in hiv
antibodies the ones that abroad at least
a subset of them bind a conserved region
but these all seem to be well okay this
one i'm not sure
how supported it is in biology but with
the conservative region you're sort of
adding extra stuff to this model
and i'm just wondering whether the setup
though conceptually
very nice it's concrete it's an
abstraction you can stimulate it
is there a better way of understanding
how the adaptive immune system works
and the reason on top of you know
having to represent broadly neutralizing
antibodies is that empirically
people have found that these broader
neutralizing antibodies have a lot of
mutations so they're very far away from
germline
and if you look at this um formulation
basically germline there's no
distinction between germline antibodies
and
affinity matured antibodies essentially
any antibody
but any germline antibody has the
potential to find
another some shape well it's just that
maybe by chance
the um the invading pathogen the evading
virus
is not well suited to the available
germline antibodies that are
that are there so you could just assume
that germline
b cells uh some uniformly distributed or
random and just by chance
an invading pathogen is not going to um
meet the one that's best suited or best
matched to it
but then you you would still get that if
you have these broadly neutralizing
antibodies against hiv they must exist
in the germline we just never see them
because they're so rare
and that is somehow unsatisfying or
possible
um what seems to be
consistent with the evidence is that
they're just germline antibodies
occupy some part of shape space that is
very far away
from what the broadly neutralizing
antibodies should be
and that's germline you mean germline
plus the junctional variation yes
yeah a primary repertoire
also uh it's been empirically noted that
the primary repertoire drama antibodies
tend to be very weak
in general that's probably why they can
be activated by
a lot of different um shapes
so it seems like germline antibodies are
some
fundamentally different than the
antibodies that can then be produced
over affinity maturation yes
so when you say the neutralizing
antibodies are nutritionally far away
from the
uh germline that's genetic mutations
right
yes so do you know that they're far away
in antigenic space
that's a good question some aspects of
them yeah some aspects of them could be
so they found that some broadly
neutralizing antibodies have a long
cdr3 cdr h3 loop
if you know what that means and some of
those antibodies are generated through
many mutations to get that loop
but it's also known that there are
germline antibodies that also have that
long loop
so it's true we don't know whether this
heavily mutated state is due to the
amount of time
that's elapsed since the infection or
and therefore you know if we just had
the right conditions at the beginning
we would have selected the right
germline or if like there was some
meaning to all the mutations that
occurred
right does that answer questions i will
just assert that it's generally not a
close correlation between how many
genetic mutations
yeah um how far are you
you mean in terms of distance from the
drum line yeah
yeah i think it's unclear when i speak
to the hiv researchers they're very
they feel that there's something
significant about the number of
mutations
anyway so just to sum up um
what i wanted to say here is that these
anti-hiv broadly neutralizing antibodies
sort of motivate us to think about the
structure of
the shape space and how the adaptive
immune system searches that structure
again maybe with you know some models
that aren't just
fit string or you could do the same
thing with euclidean space
and i feel like there's a way to
formulate the question so
first of all we need to decide is it
remarkable that in five to fifteen
mutations
the adaptive immune system can strongly
bind
a random antibody if that is remarkable
does that tell us something about the
algorithm that the immune system uses to
get there
if it's not remarkable then can we say
what it is about hiv
that makes it um get around the
immune response and so i hope there's
something there for
the computer scientists and the
evolutionary biologists and everyone in
between
some questions thanks very much
so i have a couple of things so i had
sort of assumed that the immune system
was implementing a natural selection
algorithm but
now after what you've said i'm not so
sure because um
i assumed that there was actually
several rounds of
generation selection generation and
selection going on within one
infection within one exposure right but
it sounds like from what you say
that there's only one there's you get
the antibodies
b cells coming in they proliferate
basically which is random but there's no
selection in the dark
zone there's random search and then
there's one round of selection after
that so there only seems to be one
generation
now they go back so in this picture
within one infection it can happen
there are some infections where just one
mutation will increase affinity
sufficiently there are others where
there's probably
they're probably going back but do the
iggs iggs come back later
after they've been around for a while or
is it just in a very short period
i think that's unknown i think it's in a
short period almost all numbers are
unknown
there's a difference between the second
thing is if you go to that graph with
the numbers of mutations
that is that the number that's not the
total number of mutations that have been
done
for exploration that's like how many
find at the end because that's how
you're
supposed to reach fixation or whatever
that doesn't tell you how much search
there's been
it's just how many mutations you find on
the vh gene
from the ones you sampled after
explosion yes but that could have been
huge that doesn't correlate with the
amount of surge that that was
yeah almost all the binding energy
between the epitope and the antibodies
explained by five amino acids so those
numbers are
more than enough to explain most of the
binding energy variation
but i have a hypothesis and since i
don't know the literature it's probably
already been refuted because it's an
obvious one
but the broadly neutralizing antibodies
they tend to bind to is a technical term
to what are
not immunodominant antigens so an
immunodominant antigen
when you have the initial competition in
in the germinal center
there are lots of things that the b
cells could bind to on the virus
but some of them elicit a very strong
binding response
and those are things that are well
exposed but the things that are well
exposed
often are the things that are the most
variable in hiv and are not constrained
so what happens is that the initial
immune response
is to the things that are most exposed
but also easiest to change
and therefore they're not broadly
neutralizing the things that are
don't change very much that are
conserved also tend to be somewhat
hidden
and so they tend not to elicit the
strongest immune response and so the
initial
germinal center reaction which creates
the so-called immunodominant antibodies
tends not to bind to the things that are
most conserved
but if you have a lineage of antibodies
of b cells which subsequently really
sort of by random drift and mutation
accumulate not by hypermutation but just
by accident accumulate enough mutations
so that they
by accident start to bind to these
subdominant
but but highly conserved and constrained
antigens
they can by accident discover
and become broadly neutralizing
antibodies
without really being a process of i
don't know what sort of selection
feedback there is
which is which explains why they're in
such low frequency because if they were
strongly selected they wouldn't be in
high frequency
so you would expect by chance that the
subdominant
antigens which are conserved and
potentially broadly neutralizing
would just be discovered by the
population of
antibodies which are actually tuned to
other antigens
yeah i think that's what they believe is
happening the goal is
how can you design a vaccine strategy
that would get around that somehow to
elicit
the sub immunodominant response how does
this explain
that they don't they're not they're not
beneficial to the host
i'm sorry how does this explain that
they're not beneficial to the host i
mean
what she said is that the the the
particular
person or we mentioned
because they're in too low of frequency
so the idea is that so they're
accidentally discovered
if they just accidentally discovered
then they wouldn't have any benefit
another explanation but if they're if
they're administered
or the monkey yeah so they're there
so you can even also think of it as they
they were somehow selected
but the virus response was so quick in
terms of diversifying that
um they just overwhelmed that immune
response
so they would seem that the question
about why is it that the
broadly neutralizing ones somehow are
very different
than the the b cells germline and
initial mutation
and before the mutations presumably hiv
could have evolved so that going from
one person to another
it has evolved to be further away from
the
uh the b cells that first get produced
right so that
given how fast hiv evolves that's
something which could have driven it
away
from the cells which are the b cells
which are quickly produced
and therefore that you're much more
likely to need a lot of mutations in
order to find the board
yeah so that's a good point except i
think i'm not as familiar with this
literature but i think the transmitted
serbia
hiv has two terrorism cx cr5 and
cc ccr5 and cxcr4
r5 happens early and i think x4 seems to
develop later in infection
and they find that the transmitted hiv
consistently seem to be r5 tropic
not r4 so if you if the hypothesis
is that hiv during the course of
infection is evolving away from the
immune response and somehow that's
linked to this infection in the course
of going from one individual to another
in the transmission
the transmission is
but it's unclear what sort of holes
there are in the natural
antibody rapid form that would be
consistent from person to person but
that
happens
than you would get
well but the initial repertoire is binds
very weakly to it and
and then they bind to a broad range of
things so
what you mean by a whole is ambiguous
but it has to be a lot more than five
amino acids otherwise it would get
everything right away you wouldn't need
mutations so one
one interesting piece of the puzzle
possibly to frame it as a
computer science problem is to also
think about the
requirements for uh avoiding
autoimmunity
i don't i don't know as much about the
moral branch so you could maybe
comment on that a little bit but i
wonder if you wanted to say something
about
uh that that part of the story as well
because that seems at least as
seems like an enormous constraint on the
system that we're not talking about
yeah so i didn't mention it but there is
um research done that shows that the
broadly neutralizing antibodies
may be correlated with ones that
recognize self
they would be purged early on and if
that is the case
then it's very difficult to get them
because
yeah so that's another part of the
puzzle
so one of the questions again naively
from the computer science point of view
does location play a role here in the
sense that hiv when it first invades is
in the bloodstream and can be attacked
by b
cells and later when it enters the cells
that cannot be attacked anymore is
something like that going on so yeah
that's going on sir so the beast doesn't
discover
two years after the infections when you
were saying yeah maybe it's too late
because the
the hiv is already in the cells and
cannot be fought by the immune system
so that's part of it i think what you're
asking is so one
what we measure is in the blood so we
could be measuring
freely floating antibodies that have
already served their role
in some other part of the body and we
don't know so everything we know about
hiv infection in humans
is from blood samples and there's a lot
of other stuff happening in places we
can't access
so we don't know what's going on there
infected individuals continue to have a
significant tighter in their blood
so there's always exposure
thanks